the iconic bachelor mansion in Southern
California also affected by the fires
but still standing okay this is a seven
point four million dollar sprawling
property that you have seen on many many
seasons of The Bachelor and et had
learned from a source over the weekend
that the mansion had survived there's a
question of whether it would make it
through the fires because that whole
neighborhood it's in was affected but we
worked the phones to get in touch with
the owner you're seeing him here et's
Kevin Frazier speaking to him
exclusively in this interview Kevin's
been out in those damaged areas wearing
a mask most of the time he got taken
inside the house by the owner Marshall
harridan who you're seeing here and
talked to him about the state of the
house what areas have been affected and
what this means for the production of
the hit ABC show take a look the fire
got really really close have you had a
chance to see how close it got in some
places yeah I've had some people send me
some videos away let me show you this
you've seen have you seen this back here
this is a where all the electricity
comes in to the end of the property
mm-hmm
and that's where the pool equipment used
to be it was pretty cool so you'll
rebuild all this yes sir you know
everything here's that's that's burnt
has been you know it can be replaced and
and rebuilt better than it was the first
time what was in this structure it was
just a dead space sometimes if a TV show
came they've used it for base camp or
from for whatever they wanted to use it
for Chris isn't gonna lose his job I'll
have her ready for him you'll have it
ready in time what is the time for when
do they when does it have to go in
granted time because we specialize in
building things in a short amount of
time you do they don't really need this
building it's fun that it's just a bonus
to them when they come here but they can
use a couple trailers down here instead
of this building I noticed that there is
no damage inside but what people on TV
can't see is that it smells like smoke
in here it's yeah there's a couple
windows that were probably cracked we're
left in a hurry upstairs I'm writer and
want to cheer something like that in the
wind the house definitely a little
better the good news is this house will
be ready in time for the next batch not
this coming up one but the next one all
of them so the owner lives in the house
most of the year you guys he just leaves
during filming of bachelor and
bachelorette what is lucky here is that
the show The Bachelor is
finding down its season with Colton
Underwood right now it's approaching
filming the finale or might have just
filmed it actually we don't know that
exactly but what we do know is they
filmed all the mansion's seasons already
or it seems already that season
premieres in January so there is time
for the owner to rebuild like he said
the biggest thing there is they lost one
structure where the crew often worked
and did production but he has plans to
rebuild so the bachelor mansion back and
better than ever hopefully
[Music]